[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
police response becomes the center focus
of the investigation into a mass
shooting in texas which left 21 dead
including more than a dozen fourth
graders and kevin spacey in more hot
water as the actor faces new sexual
assault charges across the pond plus mr
depp does not deserve to be known as the
representative of perpetrators of abuse
that is what this case is about it's not
about money
it's about giving mr depp his life back
attorneys make their final plea in
rebuttal closings in the defamation
lawsuit and counterclaim case between
exes johnny depp and amber heard but
first what are the jury's options when
it comes to deciding the case of debt
versus herd we're live in fairfax
virginia law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to long prime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
after weeks of testimony a verdict could
be just around the corner in the
high-profile defamation case between
exes johnny depp and amber heard long
crimes angenette levy joins us from
outside the courthouse in fairfax county
virginia with a breakdown of what jurors
are discussing inside the deliberation
room angeannette
well jesse we can tell you that the jury
actually has gone home for the evening
on monday they deliberated from about 9
00 a.m until about 5 p.m on monday so
that was in addition to the two hours
that the jurors deliberated on friday
afternoon so the jury has a number of
questions that they must answer when
considering whether or not
amber heard defamed johnny depp when she
wrote that 2018 washington post op-ed
the headline was about sexual violence
you'll recall and judge ask karate
actually took a question from the jurors
about that sexual violence headline in
the op-ed and she consulted with
attorneys for both sides of course
before sending the answer back to the
jury
the question is does question number
three the statement is false pertain to
the headline i spoke up against sexual
violence and faced our culture's wrath
or does it pertain to the content of the
statement everything written in the
op-ed
so i think the confusion came in this
particular one because the statement in
question is the title of the op-ed
so i think they're just confused as
whether it's the whole op-ed or just the
title is the statement
and it's clear that the title is the
statement so i was going to answer to
say
the title is the statement in question
for number three is that seem
appropriate to everybody
okay and now you have to recall that the
jurors are also considering a counter
claim filed against johnny depp by amber
heard in that counter claim she alleges
that depp's attorney adam waldman
defamed her when he made comments to the
daily mail back in 2020 in which he
called her
claims of physical and sexual abuse a
hoax he said that she and her friends
use these
abuse claims as both a sword and a
shield and so the jury is considering
whether or not uh depp or adept defamed
heard and um when he waldman made those
statements as depp's agent back in 2020.
jesse
and jin i think that question from the
jury is fascinating i mean we've been
covering the case together what do you
think that means in terms of what the
jury's thinking
you know
they could just be going through the
instructions jesse you know we've been
sitting here stacy delacate and i today
thumbing through these jury instructions
37 pages or so
liability issues republication you name
it it's all in there along with the
verdict form so they could just be going
through these page by page and trying to
line you know outline things what does
this mean what does that mean and maybe
they were just confused should we take
that sexual violence headline uh and
consider it on its own or as part of the
larger op-ed so it could just be as
simple as that you know andrea i'm
looking around you this tuesday after
the
memorial day weekend it is a scene that
looks a lot different than we've seen
previously what does it look like right
now
well much different jesse you know when
we were here over you know you and i
were together here last week and we've
both been here
throughout this trial
lots of depth fans right lots of depth
fans we've talked about the line for the
wristbands
it was terrible this morning when i got
here before 7 a.m the line was basically
non-existent so a lot of those fans have
gone and now
there's a slew of media behind me
international press press from
some of the big networks the you know
the national news networks and things
like that so
they are all here waiting with us for
the verdict but long crime has been
there every day we've been covering this
trial every day and i'm glad we're able
to bring that to our viewers internet
stick around thank you so much for the
great reporting have more questions for
you still ahead on long crime daily
jurors here one final plea from
attorneys is johnny depp and amber
heard's teams present rebuttal closing
arguments then later after a gunman
fatally shoots 19 fourth graders and two
teachers in texas the law enforcement
response to the mass shooting is being
questioned
[Music]
all right welcome back everybody
continuing our coverage of the johnny
depp amber heard defamation trial before
the jury was sent back for deliberations
friday both depp and herds team was able
to get in one final word before the jury
in their rebuttal closing arguments
depp's attorney camille vasquez ended
the rebuttal by posing one final
question
ms herd cannot run away from her own
allegations now you have all heard the
evidence of what she alleged against mr
death in 2016. and you have all heard
her incredibly dramatic over the top
story of physical and sexual abuse
that story was a defamatory lie miss
heard does not deserve to be known as a
representative of survivors of abuse
and mr depp does not deserve to be known
as the representative of perpetrators of
abuse
that is what this case is about it's not
about money
it's about giving mr deb his life back
while you deliberate
ask yourselves why mr depp would put
himself through this
expose every embarrassing detail of his
life on national television
if he was guilty of anything anything
that miss heard accuses him of
we ask you we implore you
to render a verdict from mr depp
we ask you to set the record straight
that he is not the abuser she described
and that she is not the heroic survivor
she portrayed
and we ask you to tell ms heard that
what she did was wrong
and as for heard her attorneys had just
minutes left in their allotted time to
argue their final points friday jay
benjamin rottenboard asked jurors to
find in favor of heard arguing witness
testimony and evidence back up her
claims of abuse
it's this simple
if you believe that depp was abusive to
amber one time ever in any of the
various forms of abuse
not only physical verbal emotional
psychological sexual any of the ways of
abuse
then your job is very easy
and you can not only deny mr depp's
claim but you can fight for amber on her
counter claim and it's interesting that
miss vasquez just changed their theory
after six weeks she said oh well
domestic abuse just means physical abuse
that's not what mr depp said
it's not what dr curry said
it's not what dr hughes said
it's not what you know to be true you
know that the evidence that you've seen
constitutes all sorts of abuse
we ask ladies and gentlemen that you
hold mr death accountable for his
actions
stand up for victims of domestic abuse
everywhere who suffer in silence
stand up for the freedom of speech
the freedom to speak about your life
that the first amendment protects
give amber herd her voice back
give amber heard her life back
let's break it down and jeanette's back
with us from fairfax county courthouse
also joining us today is former
prosecutor melba pearson and co-host
terry austin welcome to everybody melba
start with you so if the jury finds that
heard didn't defame depp right on the
his claim how likely is it will they
find that depth through his attorney
adam waldman defamed her in the counter
claim
that's a distinct possibility jesse and
always great to be on with you here on
law and crime uh but you know that at
the end of the day the verdict can come
back in almost a split format so in
other words they'd find in favor of
amber and heard and say that she did not
defame johnny depp they may still rule
and say that johnny depp's attorney
defamed her but that doesn't necessarily
mean that they're going to attach a
monetary judgment to it so her counter
claim is 50 million the jury could come
back giving her 50 million they can come
back giving her a dollar something
symbolic so it's going to be very
interesting to see how this ends up
being broken down at the end of the
deliberation no doubt terry there's a
lot for the jury to consider i mean
amber heard claimed that depp repeat her
repeatedly do you think there's one
incident that maybe like really stands
out that he could have physically or
sexually assaulted her
well i think the jury is going to look
at all of these incidents and say you
know she lied about one she probably
lied about them all the only one
incident that did have some
corroboration was the incident where her
makeup artist came and tended to her
injuries and put makeup on her now
frankly the makeup artist can't say
where those injuries came from and she
did say she did not see depp hit amber
heard but i did think that witness was
credible
and jeanette my understanding is we've
had a development that depp's team has
moved for revised jury instruction they
took issue with something that happened
during closings
that's right jesse they filed a motion
on tuesday morning for a curative
instruction they wanted judge asked
karate to tell the jury basically that
they felt that
ben rottenborn during his closing
argument made some sort of inappropriate
comment in which he said basically your
verdict is going to send a message to
all victims of domestic violence
basically if you find for johnny depp
it's going to send this terrible message
to all of these victims of domestic
violence and these survivors so uh they
wanted a curative instruction on that
and they filed a motion for that but
judge asked karate when she answered the
jurors questions she brought this up and
addressed it and she said look you know
it's already in the jury's hands it's
basically too late so she did not take
up the motion or granted
and look that was a really powerful
moment in his closing arguments so it'll
be interesting to see you know if they
actually consider that because you know
the idea of what a alleged survivor
should do or not do has been a difficult
question that we've been answering in a
lot of these uh kind of sexual assault
cases anjanet alevi thank you so much
great reporting as always from fairfax
county virginia and a new development in
the case of idaho doomsday cult duo chad
dabell and lori valo dabel as a motion
to move the start of lori's trial is
granted chad and lori reportedly met in
2018 through mutual beliefs about the
end of the world while chad was still
married to his first wife tammy dabal
the pair now face first degree murder
charges for the deaths of lori's two
children j.j valo and tyler ryan and for
the death of chad's first wife tammy
whose death was initially determined to
be from natural causes jj and tyler were
last seen on september of 2019 but lori
and chad never reported them missing
police say the couple fled out of state
before the kids remains were found on
chad's property nine months after their
disappearance laurie was initially
declared mentally unfit to stand trial
but that has since changed laurie was
set to go on trial in october but the
judge delayed her case to preserve a
single trial the two will face the death
penalty in their joint trial scheduled
to begin in january
and in california the second theranos
trial focused on elizabeth holmes's
former business partner and boyfriend
ramesh sunny balwani has been postponed
this as holmes is asking for a judge to
overturn her conviction balwani faces
several federal charges accused of
defrauding investors and customers after
touting theranos as a revolutionary
breakthrough technology and blood
testing prosecutors seek to convince a
jury that balwani conspired with homes
to scam investors out of millions of
dollars while he served as the company's
co
holmes was convicted in january of three
counts of wire fraud and one count of
conspiracy to commit fraud in relation
to theranos's downfall now holmes is
asking a judge to overturn the jury's
decision saying there was insufficient
evidence to convict holmes is set to be
sentenced in september she faces up to
20 years in prison no reason was given
for the delay in balwani's trial but it
is expected to start back up june 7.
and coming up on long crime daily
two-time oscar winner actor kevin spacey
facing more allegations of sexual
misconduct plus after a gunman opens
fire in a fourth grade classroom
questions surround the police response
to the ovalty texas shooting now the
department of justice is stepping in to
investigate
[Music]
welcome back everybody actor kevin
spacey is facing sexual misconduct
allegations once again the award-winning
actor faces charges in the united
kingdom the charges were announced last
week consisting of four counts of sexual
assault against three men and one charge
of causing a person to engage in
penetrative sexual activity without
consent the alleged incidents happened
while spacey served as the artistic
director of the old vic theater in
london the 62 year old cannot be
formally charged unless he
enters either england or wales spacey
spokesman tells media outlets that the
actor does plan to travel to britain to
defend himself saying he's confident he
can prove his innocence if spacey does
not travel to the uk voluntarily british
authorities would formally extradite him
to the united states this isn't the
two-time academy award winner's first
time running with sexual assault
allegations he's faced more than a dozen
sexual misconduct allegations since
2017. one of which was accusations of
making unwanted sexual advances towards
rentstar anthony rapp in the 1980s when
he was just 14 years old shortly after
spacey issued a lengthy apology on
social media after raps allegations were
made public at least 20 people who
worked with spacey in london accused him
of inappropriate behavior so mel but the
question is and i know you're not an
expert in uk law but why do you think
that these charges are coming out now
and do you think it's going to be a
tough case to prosecute
well this is definitely part and parcel
of the metoo movement where survivors of
sexual abuse of assault are feeling more
empowered and also we've seen the
evolution of how people look at abuse
and are moving away from blaming
survivors and also views on people being
gay have evolved as well so i think now
that these gentlemen are older they're a
little bit more settled in their careers
they may have been able to go through
therapy and work through the trauma they
are now able to come forward and feel
comfortable and more comfortable not
that they will be comfortable but more
comfortable and speaking about these
allegations it will be tough due to the
how long it's been i mean we're talking
10 years plus but then again if their
memories are very solid and can match up
with other testimony that would be the
way for successful prosecution right
right you're seeing similarities with
other cases as well terry why do you
think spacey is returning to the uk
voluntarily it's a very curious thing to
do
you know i think if he had a
conversation with his attorneys they
probably came to the conclusion that
really they're not going to win on that
type of argument the extradition
agreement between the uk and u.s is a
very solid agreement there's no question
that the u.s is going to say yes you may
have you know kevin spacey and so they
probably decided not to do it plus jesse
if he voluntarily goes on his own he can
figure out a schedule he can work with
the uk authorities and it'll be a whole
lot easier for him for his team to go to
the trial and to work out and he says he
thinks he's going to win so he's saying
he has nothing to be afraid of so we'll
see what happens yeah i don't think he
wanted to be taken under against his
will and extradited over there and from
an optics point of view he's saying hey
listen i've got nothing to hide i get it
i get it so we'll see how that plays out
when we come back law enforcement under
fierce scrutiny after a mass shooting
left 21 people dead including 19 fourth
graders by police response to the ovale
school shooting is under a microscope
welcome back to long prime daily
everybody anger is growing after a mass
shooting took the lives of 19 elementary
students and two teachers in uvalde
texas as the department of justice says
it will investigate the police response
to the incident last week officials say
18 year old salvador ramos shot and
injured his grandmother before crashing
into his truck into a ditch near robb
elementary school authorities say ramos
entered the school building through a
propped open door several police
officers entered the building minutes
later but they waited outside the
classroom after 77 minutes a tactical
team entered the room and fatally shot
the gunman 19 4th graders and two
teachers were killed in the rampage
texas officials and law enforcement have
been under intense scrutiny about how
the shooting was handled the incident
has also prompted renewed calls for gun
control measures the doj says the
investigation aims to quote provide an
independent account of law enforcement
actions and responses that day and to
identify lessons learned and best
practices to help first responders
prepare for and respond to active
shooter events funerals are scheduled
throughout the week to lay the victims
to rest so melbourne start with you what
exactly can the doj do here what powers
authority do they have i mean what can
they do after they investigate
well let's start with this first of all
i definitely want to center the the
victims and their families that they've
left behind because no matter what the
doj does they will never be able to
bring those poor souls back so we start
with that but what they can do is bring
to light the failures that occurred on
that day and that report that they can
that they will eventually issue can be
used number one within the texas
legislature or by the governor to be
able to guide what should happen to law
enforcement moving forward it can be a
tool if for instance the police chief of
volvalde is elected or if he's appointed
this could result in the removal from
his position because there's evidence in
that report that shows he he was you
know
engaged in malfeasance in some way shape
or form if there are systemic problems
that the doj finds within the department
they could go the route of a consent
decree which means that changes in
overhaul would have to happen within the
department and the doj
oversees and supervises that process by
assigning a monitor that seems to happen
a lot within police shooting cases so
something like that could happen here as
well okay so it has some teeth but terry
you know it sounds like we're also
agreeing that there was a failure to
follow police policy and protocol do you
think that there is a potential for
civil litigation here as well
absolutely i think that there will be
civil litigation and as melvin said that
doesn't mean that it'll bring anyone
back obviously but it will send a
message here there was many many
failures to follow the protocol it was a
active shooter not a barricaded suspect
as the police were thinking they should
not have waited over an hour there were
at least eight calls from inside the
school including children they really
should have gone in and they should have
put their lives behind the lives of the
children the children's lives should
have come first and so i do think that
we're going to see lawsuits out of this
they should have gone in and confronted
that attacker and they failed to follow
their own manual so we'll see what
happens but i think there will be
litigation and a lot of people want
answers for what happened there melba
terry thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice
[Music]
you